hello hello good morning it's an honor
to meet you I've loved you since I was a
kid just oh so too often st. John how's
the talks going for Dino charge coming
for Power Rangers Dino charge series
talks for Dino charge yeah well as of
right now they've been going on for
about a couple of seconds no actually
I've spoken with the executive producers
for the company once I got back from the
Middle East
chip is one of the current executive
producers and I was in the Middle East
over the last four years working as a
medic and I met with chip in Pasadena
and he explained to me that they spent
the last couple of seasons where I was
not available I was in the Middle East
bringing back some of the original
Rangers so I kind of missed that boat he
says but now that we know that you're
back you know we'll have to see what the
future holds we don't I think he doesn't
see anything coming in the next couple
of seasons but he was excited to hear
from me I was excited to talk to him
and we'll see what happens so no
contracts no promises but you never know
when to be exciting to see the Red
Ranger backyard should I shave
everybody's like you need to shave like
I kind of I know don't shave ma'am I'll
be the bearded Ranger yeah not the
bearded lady the bearded Ranger let's
keep that stranger I have a question off
to the side from a gentleman in a
Pikachu have to understand out okay this
is just a general question to all of you
what's your favorite of the later Power
Ranger series oh gosh that's a hard
question because the thing is is when we
were on the show we didn't watch the
show when we were there so we haven't
really seen the later see
I can tell you who my some of my
favorite people are I absolutely love
Erin Cahill I love that entire cast I've
become really good friends with them I
love the Kia barrese I love cat I love
Azeem you know I've become really good
friends with them yeah so I mean I love
all of them I haven't had the
opportunity to see their shows though
any of you guys yeah I've met so many I
had no idea home in either word like
probably 90 is there that many that's
crazy
it's funny because when we get together
we don't really talk Power Rangers we
just like talk hey what's up how you
doing uh it's more like it's a PTSD for
Power Rangers like you never believe we
didn't walk uphill in the snow both ways
it's pretty amazing to think that here
we are 21 years later and there's been
so many different casts of flower
Rangers I mean I'm just happy that we
started it all you know somebody told me
that this season the show is going to
hit episode yeah yeah Mighty Morphin
with the longest it did like 200
episodes that's great episode purses
turning into monsters yeah you would
think they'd run out I mean they did
turn a person to a month so I think
they're running out of the oyster Iser
I got a great question thank you big
good question
okay who has it well there's a hat try
to keep your hands in the air so I can
see you and get you quick up yeah yeah
yeah low this is directed to Walter
Jones
I love hi do you still dance moves
so for those of you who may have been
out on the town last night I'm pretty
sure there was some salsa going on
because this guy and I were salsa him
yes I love sauce um I'm actually a world
champion salsa dancer it's been my way
to continue dancing which I love so much
and I hope we have a crystal to middle
at the back hey guys it's nice to see
you as probably everyone here growing up
what she has been fantastic my sister's
fiance is extremely jealous because he
was fanatical value guys his mummy being
forbidden want you to try my stairs
however the question I want to ask you
guys is what do you think about the
recent movie reboot that's been going on
cuz I've seen some images Lord Zedd
looks really evil I've only seen one
picture the Red Ranger little bit black
Ranger's meant to be a street fighter
just let me get your ideas ports on that
if you have any more information thanks
for telling us how it is yeah I think
it's amazing I think I think it's great
for the fandom you guys have been asking
for it forever and I think they're very
smart to do a reboot of Mighty Morphin
because that was probably the most
popular out of all the series and who
knows you guys got to write them lots of
letters and tell them that we all need
to make cameos in that movie they need
the Mighty Morphin casters show up I'm
excited about the movie I think the fact
the reboot movies gonna inspire an
entire different generation of people to
enjoy the Power Rangers and what we
started and I think it's pretty exciting
cuz I'm like wow I mean guys it's 21
years later and here we are we're still
still talking about it was still doing
it and a new movie especially a movie in
the vein of like transformers would be
really exciting yeah and we have a
question towards the front oh yeah I
grew up watching you over time and I
still watch it now I have all of the
Mighty Morphin episodes you my
nine-year-old brother who was born in
2005 I sit with him and watch it all the
time carrying on from the last question
if say you asked right this second to be
in the reboot even as a cameo like what
would you say it's morphin time
Triceratops yeah I think we would all be
very totally open to it and would love
to do it oh yeah I'm question for a
gentleman here as well hello guys I'm
from Qatar long income I think I'm some
where were you in the Middle East I was
wait anyways my question is was it
personally knowings or done you know I
was found he was given orders he was
very bossy yeah you know do this beat up
that guy you know it's like oh you wore
spandex ah you sent us places yeah you
know some of the hardest parts was
actually when we had sit-down and always
shave his head there was that one
Christmas he's forgot to get his guess
yeah we need to make like Christmas
balls for the Christmas tree with a
balls or Tanya question from a lady at
the front a lady in the front he's gonna
get his work out and yeah hi have you
got any funny stories from um sat Oh
you want me to tell my they're all like
they're all related for me they're all
related to Jason David Frank
yeah he's the prankster he was he was
the biggest jokester on set and the one
that I tell and he tells a lot is the
famous fly story once I was stuck in the
command center shooting a bunch of
scenes and I wasn't able to leave Seth
and I was starving and I was really
hungry and Jason I hung out a lot we
were best friends and I used to babysit
his children so he said oh don't worry
Dave well I'll go make you a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich tonight and so
I thought oh wow he's been a good friend
he's gonna go make me a sandwich and so
he brought me a sandwich back and I ate
it and then I start seeing a bunch of
people start laughing and I'm like
what's going on and Jason's like oh I
put a fly in your sandwich so I had a
peanut butter touji in the Life magazine
and that was one of his pranks but he
was he was quite the prankster he also
broke up brush on my head once I was I
was sitting on the makeup chair and he
came up behind me with a brush he went
and it snapped on my head I mean it
didn't mean to break but I knew he was
hard-headed
I remember I was 17 18
I was extremely young and naive now I'm
just old and naive yeah and I remember
the very first gay man that I met his
name was Carlos he was our makeup artist
and my father was a Marine my mom was a
police officer so there wasn't much of
that around my house when I met Carlos
he was super friendly outgoing I love
him to death but I had never been around
a very open feminine gay man and I
remember I sat down on the chair and he
was yes so I just love your eyelashes I
mean he's right here in my face well you
have very lovely eyelashes yeah very
lovely eyes you think
and then I came to love Carlos he was
the coolest dude but that was a little
bit scary and so we used to play pranks
on Carlos like I forgot about some of
that yeah we like take his water
spritzer he'd be working on somebody
next to me I grabbed his water spread
with anguish in the back of the head you
know 17 Oh with a water cannon why would
you do then we used to do this thing on
the set it wasn't really a prank but it
was like we'd be in the command center
and we stopped for episodes every two
weeks so when we and we shot out of
order so when we were in the command
center we'd be shooting four different
episodes so it's a full day of the
command center just I'm sorry too
disheartened
the command center there is nothing
there it's like it's all green screen so
it's like one big huge green screen and
there's like a thing hanging up with a
piece of paper on it and that's what we
were looking at to look at Zordon so
we'd be looking at this paper all day
and we get so bored that we just mess
with each other like this and you take
the energy from your legs to your body
and you punch forward and we would
challenge each other to one-inch bunches
in the middle of the set sometimes we
got knocked over the same they were
still one-inch punch in yeah each other
that's a lot of fun don't do that at
home yeah I mean a question in the
middle hi I just want to say how awesome
it is to finally meet you guys you guys
are like my heroes growing up there
where's your accent um American I was
shut down yeah anyway my question is for
you guys what was your least favorite
scene to shoot or your favorite she'd
seen the shoes mm-hmm realize there's
like 400 episode 5 - favorite scene the
shoot was actually in the movie we had
you know we jumped out of the plane and
did the whole like skydiving scene
everybody got to go and they were all we
were doing like
green screen they had a stuff probably
as high as this ceiling and he would
flip flip flip and then post for the
camera flip flip flip and kind of do
that thing
well everybody got to go and I was the
last one to shoot they were like oh
we'll shoot you after dinner
so like yay great so we had dinner and
sure enough maybe 30 minutes after they
pulled me up and it's like flip flip
flip flip flip flip good and so I'm just
like throwing up like like yeah like
it's like flying out of my mouth like
really bad but I'm 80 feet up in the air
and they just like Jason Frank I think
David were taking pictures they've never
surfaced thankfully I was just like they
had to cover the camera and it took them
like another 15 minutes to get me down
so I just violently threw up for like 15
minutes least favorite scene the least
favorite scene the shoe one of my
favorite scenes or what some of the
themes of my favorite things to do were
the fighting that was always fun and you
know we fought the parties a lot but a
lot of times they would put us together
so Austin and I would have to spar or
where I would spar with Jason Frank and
Huntley Billy and I are required but
that was always a lot of fun cuz martial
artists and a little bit of ego so we
would just be inspired to be like really
good you know we have to do it fast and
Austin and I we would start doing
something and it's supposed to be like
this okay we're gonna do like this maybe
hang with this it was like it was so
much we go so fast we're like child each
other to be better I think my favorite
scene was the dance-off with bulk
because we I did that dance-off but I
had to do I did these spins right five
turns I've never ever in my life done
five turns again or before that and so
it was captured on film so it lives
forever
I think he's just crazy and likes to
spin we don't even talk about all the
spinach probably my least favorite scene
had to have been in the first five
episodes and it involved pineapple the
plan
I hate pineapple actually I really like
the guy actually met the guy
a really nice guy we're doing a
convention I hate is he gonna be there
so again I'm 1718 completely immature
young guy and there was a scene where I
had to come running around the corner
with Dave and wall and Amy Joe was there
too he was still there and we come run
around a corner and I had to be like
dead serious I was leader you're going
down clown and I begged bag dude the
director please don't make me say that
can I change it I'm gonna take you down
man can I cut out I'm gonna kick your
butt something please like does it have
to be here going down cloud please don't
make me do that you did it so well any
many being so but that was early in the
season you know very first season where
basically it was like marching orders
you will say this and you will look this
way and you're gonna be this intense and
everything you must say must be you know
like with the like bad Japanese movie
you know with the well it was partially
yeah a bad like lip-sync now you must be
you know so when I was doing that it was
like I hated that I hated that I really
needed that line once I loved that were
so many like I love the one where Walt
had a spider dropped on his shoulder
because the spider was gonna eat him and
I knew it and I was like they said when
the spider did that that was bad and
he's doing that on your shoulder like at
your neck yeah and but anyway it all
worked out well they'd fed him a bunch
of crickets they're like he's not gonna
eat you Walter and he tried to eat
Walter and I loved that I thought it was
funny
and so we ended up he he ended up taking
home the spider and named him homie and
he and I were in the same house with
some of the stunt guys because you know
they didn't pay as well enough to live
alone very well at least not most of us
and so homie lived in an aquarium in our
wall for years now I understand homies
not just a spider it's it's a ranch
Allah wait
big old transyl a big good guy but he
didn't buy me it was kind of scary
because they put a fake trench alone my
shoulder at first and that was fine and
then they go cut and they come in and
they put a road French on my shoulder
and I've never even seen a tarantula a
real tarantula and I'm like ok this is
safe right and they're like don't worry
about his clients fine as long as he
doesn't we're up he won't bite you and
then director goes now look at the
spider and scream and I go and this
fighter goes I'm really sweetly and
really sting me get him off I was like
oh that's bad he said that was bad I
mean I I had a lot of great moments that
I like said that 200 episodes but
usually in the first season those were
always the funnest for me to film the
episode where Amy Jo and I switched
places it's called switching places
where she became Billy and I became
Kimberly that was a lot of fun and she
and I also got to do one called Power
Ranger pumps where we became kind of
like evil bad pumps that was a lot of
fun I was John you were jealous yeah
yeah I mean there's so many good things
I'm the only scene that I didn't like
filming was again in the first season
Billy my character created something
called the rat bug and it was like an
old via VW bug that flew around the city
I don't even know how that happened and
anyways we had to shoot a scene where
all five of us were stuck in the rat bug
and Amy Jo farted and we were Charlie's
fire we were trapped with her smell and
we had to keep active it was not fun
that was my least favorite scene so she
ate carrots that day
it was wrong amy-jo we have we have a
question here in the middle from cowboy
depo hi guys from Italy it's a good
feeling to see ok what is the fail to
driving Megazord
it feels very powerful to be the front
keep coming up with French hi it's a
pleasure to meet you all
I know you've sort of already done the
it's morphin time but if I handed you my
Morpher would you do it properly you
know what I would love to do I would
love to get everybody together at the
end of the convention and do a group
more for London that we can post on our
Facebook pages for all of you would you
guys be down with that walk together ok
so we will end with a giant group for
this is gonna be awesome
oh there's so many people right here to
go with narrow suit cosplay I know my
question is how great wasn't working
with other red Rangers and forever red
question yeah you know I I had travelled
a lot I kind of left the Hollywood scene
I don't even remember how they got ahold
of me anymore but when they called me up
they're like hey we're doing this
episode with the other Red Ranger so I
was like cool like 2 or 3 you know cuz I
knew that Cardenas is calm I knew Jason
Frank was red after a Covina's and I
thought yeah maybe one more I was wrong
so they told me there's like no there's
I think they said they're gonna 11 or 12
at that time and Steve didn't make that
that episode but when I show when they
told me my jaw dropped I came
but I got there and I met these guys and
they were all cool you know we were part
of the leadership family and you know we
just shook hands and they were like some
of these guys were like I grew up
watching you as a damn I'm old
yeah but they were all really cool guys
you know we showed up we did our things
and it was like a day and a half on two
different locations we did the fight
scene in what was an old power because
it was like a power plant in LA doing
flips doing our thing and the guys were
all very talented all of them were or at
least I think maybe all but one where I
had a significant history accomplished
martial arts so it was really great to
meet him it was really neat to see how
the history or show it continued
question for gentleman here yes hello I
would like to ask how did it feel
meeting Gehrke from your Japanese
counterpart it's caught
yeah we we actually spent a good portion
of the evening after we met having
dinner we had a couple of years together
we talked about maybe I shouldn't we
talked about I can't tell you everything
we've talked about we talked about maybe
how absolutely nuts it would be if the
original Japanese Ranger and the
original Red Ranger were put together a
movie and how the fans might respond to
that something crazy like you know the
Yakuza meets up with you know me and we
hate each other in the beginning and
things go on then we just end up kicking
butt all over Japan you know people
flying kicks going and we had a great
time you know I had a couple of beers
and the stories got even better so one
of these days I think where we've left
it now is that I need to make my way out
to Japan and spend a little time with
him but he was he was really a cool guy
and it's funny cuz there's a here the
original Red Ranger and I met him and he
was like no no there's been 26 you're
like ready 26 and we had a translator
because he didn't speak much English
number one number 26 so it was great it
was really cool to see the man who had
created something I was able to continue
in the english-speaking world
Italian French Spanish and a few other
places okay we've got time for one more
question and it is gonna be from this
gentleman here hello hey one question
I've got is what was the audition
process like when you were first
auditioning to become the Power Rangers
in the original cast it was probably a
good six to eight week process there was
thousands of people that auditioned for
Power Rangers I originally started
auditioning for the Red Ranger and I had
three auditions for that and I realized
I wasn't gonna get that role so I begged
the casting director and the producers
to let me read for Billy and they did
and then I had five more auditions for
that for Billy and I was one of the
lucky ones out of the thousands that got
the role but it was a long it was a long
process you know and we moved LA to be
an actor it's like you you want the job
so bad and it's hard because you have to
go on for so many weeks what was it like
for you I have no idea what I was doing
I wasn't an active like oh these guys
had experience I was
what's a mark you understand on what the
old lights stand face to lights yeah I
was seventeen they were like here's a
monologue as a way to monologue and read
this and be excited you're gonna save
the world okay and it was just really
cheesy monologue for a show called
phantoms it wasn't called Power Rangers
and they had me do lots of martial arts
lots of martial artists we did the final
audition of 20th Century Fox and I had
this choreographed fight with your Masha
Bev Tadashi who was an amazing
a bunch of big movies and I actually he
kept pushing me to do this one kick
really fast at full speed I was like no
I've been doing this a long time not as
long as him he was a master I had a
black belt at the time and I was like
even I knew I was like I'm gonna kick
you in him if you make me do this full
speed I didn't want to do it I want to
do it anyone do it all the big wigs for
20th Century Fox the last day we're all
in this like big table area and he was
like do it so I did it and I kicked him
right upside the head
well he was a pro like he rolled out of
it caught up walked around and he came
back and he's looking like he played it
up you never knew then it was like this
bad thing and when he came back around I
was like I'm about to die he's gonna
kill me right here but I lived that's
cool I don't know so anyway that was my
sleep I am and when I walked into the
room they're like okay so this guy Zack
he's gonna do the pop he dough so Kiki
dance hip-hop purse and they put on some
music that was some really bad music it
was like not hip-hop at all and so I
like this and hip hop dancing like I got
that right they said not to do some
martial arts right martial arts I can do
that did like a little kata
it can't do any clips like well this
room is small but I can did a backflip
you know knock that out okay good
now keep putting together in a way okay
not about something came up with some
moves
Paquito one of the other casts this guy
named Wylie was very challenging
he actually his version of hip-hop kita
was like Michael Jackson
so he's dancing like Michael Jackson and
fighting which I don't know how that
would have gone over but I was really
happy that I was able to create that
form and it was cool it was cool
I remember Austin he said he wasn't an
actor he was very new at acting yeah I
guess I think I think I will have a
phone remember right he came to the
audition on a bed
somebody said I bet you won't go in
audition for this part
you did and we got in the room we had to
do the scene together and I'm an actor I
had already had a degree in musical
theater and they tell me that that I
helped him a lot when we were in the
room together because I was carrying him
through the scene kind of like making
sure he had his lines and giving him
motivations and but we worked out we had
this great chemistry you know we were
friends and it came across he's good
yeah well for our audition obviously you
guys know the show was already
established and we didn't know
originally that we were going to be
replacing Rangers they kind of just had
an open call audition in the paper to be
on a TV show and that's why I was like
okay I'm there I'll show up and I mean
literally I showed up and there were
thousands of people like it looked like
the line that you guys had to stand in
just to get into this place I mean it
was huge it was crazy
and so we literally went in and they
weren't so nice to me they were like you
had that there be a dancer or martial
artists or a gymnast and so we've read
our little monologue but they weren't so
nice they didn't have any music so I was
like oh I brought you I brought music
they're like we don't have a radio but
you had like 60 seconds so I just
started dancing and the lady just kind
of looked at me and was like can you
come back you know this afternoon so the
thousands of people turned into like a
few hundred and we came back and this
time they had music and we got to you
know and they taped us and I think it
was probably two days later they called
us it like at the crack of dawn I was
like early in the morning they were like
can you get on a plane tomorrow to go
out to ship for producers and I was like
heck yeah and so they were like you're
just gonna be there overnight and you
know he's taking selfies you're just
gonna be there overnight so like okay so
we brought like two outfits they put us
in this like seedy hotel we got there we
went in auditioned and literally we have
to go in by ourselves and then they put
us as groups and they literally put me
Steve and Johnny together first group we
went in and I got to see them do their
audition to this day we're like I really
just blew my mind what they did and and
just to kind of be a part of that moment
and
then they kind of mix this up put us in
a little couple different groups but by
really like two hours later they set
everybody in the room together she's
like 20 people satis in a room and they
were like okay you you and you you got
the part okay oh my god
but then the other people were like
crying and upset we were like sad for
them but happy for ourselves and it was
crazy but they were like four days later
they were like you tell your parents to
FedEx your clothes you you now live in
LA and you start work on Monday so my
process was a lot different than theirs
but it was crazy
you